chelsea get us out of this what's up
okay i'm a little nervous you're gonna
have to bear with me okay but
um i'm a stay-at-home mom and i'm trying
to
start a side hustle planning murder
mystery parties
but i'm like almost totally blind
and i'm not sure how upfront i should be
with my clients about that because i
don't want to be
disingenuous with them since it is a
visual
medium involved but at the same time
it's like it's my medical record
is that really their business i'm just
i'm not sure what to do because i don't
want to mislead people
flip shoes
you were going to a murder mystery place
would you care if the lady that put it
on
was blind not really unless
unless they couldn't do the job oh ding
ding ding ding ding ding ding you win
the award can you plan awesome parties
yes and to the extent that your site
limitation
would cause a mistake you can go ahead
and disclaim that on the front end and
people give you a lot of grace
okay that's a good idea i didn't think
about it but but you go look
but it's not a thing i got this yeah and
if i don't got it you can call me out on
it and we'll work it out together but i
got it i've done 26 of these or whatever
you've done and
there's no no problems and so on but um
chelsea you throw that head back and go
yeah have at it
but just treat other people like you'd
want to be treated it solves
almost all your business ethics
questions
okay and i yeah and by the way if i were
your customer that's exactly what i
would want
i don't care if i'm coming in there to
have a party and have fun
if the person conducting it is whatever
fill in the blank
i want an awesome party i don't care
until their whatever
affects my party right but if it affects
my party
uh and it's an and i need to have a
little bit of compassion with that
person or a little bit i'd like to have
had a heads up about that let's have a
conversation about it yeah
but so i don't get surprised because i
really you know like i'll tell you i'll
give you an example okay
i went to check into a hotel a while
back and uh we use only debit cards
and the stupid debit card had gotten an
algorithm hit for i'd
for id right for id theft
and i and uh then the people come back
from the uh
desk and they go well you're over your
limit
well honey my debit card don't have a
limit
okay this is freaking me it's got i can
do i can buy a car on my debit
card if i want to right so but um it's
late at night i'm tired i'm exhausted
and i can't get a stupid hotel and i'm
pissed at my bank
i dial up my personal banker
and i was unhappy with her can you
imagine me doing that
yeah to which she says hey i'll get this
fixed in the morning
i'm at the visitation
for my dad's funeral can i work on it in
the morning
to which dave goes oh you're a butt to
dave
he says to himself gave the butt you
know you
so in other words if i had had that
piece of information i might have been a
little nicer to her right you follow me
yeah so just give me enough information
so that i can be kind
if i'm the customer if there's a mistake
that uh might be related to the
information
and chelsea i think what's gonna cause
you the most grief
is if you walk into business deals
self-conscious of something
if you think you're bringing um an
impairment to something
then you're gonna not sell yourself as
strongly go in with your head held high
you're gonna do a great job yeah a
community with you is gonna help you
fill in your gaps
man you're going to go get it the reason
we know you're going to be good is you
bothered to ask the questions awesome
you weren't like arrogant and throwing
around i love it entitlement stuff
i love it you just said hey how would
you how should you do this